well one time um one time cuz I call his
butt steam buns steam one time like
during prayer I was like thank you God
for making those T juicy little steam
buns and he started laughing right he
start he started laughing and then the
next day he I think he was like oh that
was funny so he was like thank you thank
you God for making my mom have those
juicy steam dude that's joke
[Music]
Jackie welcome back to careful boys
where we are going to talk about the
happiest moment of your life so far the
happiest wo the Happ happiness is now
dude right here oh jeez you walk right
into that I'll tell you the saddest
moment is just I was
waiting I wanted to see your reaction
right now D yeah I don't know if I've
ever had like like a
huge Catalyst moment but kind of going
off of what like K is saying there are
moments of bliss in the weirdest times
that shouldn't happen for me but like a
realization like I remember me and
Hannah were Night Swimming in in and on
the beach in aahu and then I was like
just looking up at the sky and I was
like what the it's it's it's
happened and then she's like what and
I'm like I can't believe that just a
couple years ago I said I'm going to
open up a shop here and I'm just going
to live in Hawaii for a little bit and
I'm doing it living the dream that's
cool and it's a crazy feeling cuz when
you're it was really stressful doing it
all and when you're in it it's one of
those things where you're like oh man I
bit off sh why did I do this like why
did I do this this is crazy like
I'm in debt I'm like this is not what I
imagine like this is everyone's arguing
slinging tea all day yeah it's not what
I thought it would be and then now I'm
just swimming and I'm like oh it's
exactly how I thought it would be like
this is the part this is the this is
what made it worth it you know and then
there'll be moments like that out of
nowhere where it's just like maybe me
and Hannah's like hiking somewhere and
I'm like oh this dope and she's
like what she goes look at this view in
Vegas it's crazy like how did it
get here like we we just got a house and
and we're living here now and then like
it's kind of like all catching up I love
those moments yeah yeah you're catching
up to the moment yeah and it's like my
past self who had this goal is happy
that I'm here like I imagine that and
and it's like oh I'm settled you
manifested yeah you definitely did yeah
and that's the I think the moments of
manifesting that oh I wish this could be
real and then like couple years later it
is real and then you forget that you
dreamed of it and then you're just
sitting there like holy is really
happening there a big risk but you know
what sucks is when people get stuck on
the oh I'm not there yet I'm not there
yet and then they forget that dude
you're actually already surpassed it a
long time ago oh yeah that's true I
would say for me the happiest moment in
life so far
was the day the night before my wedding
oh because lost your virginity yeah I
lost my but I lost my
an
before and no um so so me and Nikki had
this thing where we we knew that like
there's going to be so many family and
friends in town tomorrow and when you're
at your your wedding it's like a party
but you want to thank everyone for being
there cuz especially they drove all the
way there or flew there whatever so we
just took time with each other the night
before and we just like sat down in the
hotel room together and we didn't I
know that's going to be the bit we
didn't cuz you're you're not going
to break that until after
marriage you're a good Christian boy we
just talked about our story and our life
and like what we wanted from each other
and like I'll never forget that cuz the
cliche is everyone says their wedding
day but for me it was the night before
like the wedding day cuz you got to
really absorb what was what we were
about to do yeah that's sick it was
awesome mine's kind of similar but it
was the day after our wedding and it was
the day we we had this place in Malibu
it was on the beach and then we went too
I took out my my my inflatable paddle
board I was going to town and
that thing and then Tiff sitting on the
Tiff sitting and it's like a it's a it's
a private beach and we're just sitting
down and then yeah we just look out and
then we just go I can't believe we
got married yesterday wow wow you know
what I mean and it's like thinking about
how long we've been together all
the we've been through together
and then thinking about like man what a
cool moment that was that we got
to share it with you know the the very
close loved ones in our life and to
think like man we we're only getting
started too like this is like it's is a
big moment in our life but we still have
so much forward to so much more to look
forward to uhhuh and I was like that's a
trip you know and then just
sitting on the beach and then just like
kind of looking out and we're like the
only ones on there on a like
Monday that's dope it was pretty
sweet I like realization that's a great
trying to drown tiff with the
wave mov such a good move hey is't it
crazy we got Barrett I would
argue as she regrets it dude okay let me
ask you this would it have been as cool
without the paddle board no that's the
whole point can why he said that can he
set it up yeah dude see no cuz I took
the paddle board out and it was
inflatable and I was like dude this is
not like doing this in a in a marina I'm
as soon as the paddleboard is gone I
think we should get it an old it made it
more fun this must be a omen it might
been the paddle board that made the
magic yeah it is the paddle board you
guys are you guys already know uh this
story of mine but uh one of the happiest
moments is when I when the doctor told
me I didn't have AIDS what very happy
that's Euphoria bab the
relief i'
got I think it's very it's it's super
rare in life that you'll have to go
through that when like you have uh a
unique autoimmune disease that mimics
the symptoms of HIV and then so the the
um the doctor literally did that test
and he said and he literally was like
We'll know in 30 days but I think your
HIV positive oh what who does that oh my
God and remember I told you because he
didn't say that until I told him I was a
dancer so he probably thought he was
gay so it was like a yeah it was a
really terrible thing so I spent I spent
30 stop laughing I spent 30 days
thinking that I that I probably had AIDS
I spent 30 days so then the day that he
told when I came back and he told told
me and showed me my paperwork and I was
totally clean and turns out it's like
this thing called srin syndrome or
something that just has like a lot of
like strange weird inconvenient symptoms
I literally went to the parking lot I
did a flip and I landed on my back and I
just stared at the Sun and that's what
happened a movie Celebration was the
doctor kind of disappointed when he was
like no you don't have
HIV I thought dancers were gay it's like
you said you're gay right I wrote it
about some of you gay boys just get
lucky
tell you what what kind of dancing do
you do no no he refuses to believe he's
like no he's got to be a virgin yeah I
think the feeling of like to know that I
went through that like how rare and
bespoke of a moment that is like that
doesn't happen to most people bro 30
days thinking you have HIV is a long
that's true cuz sometimes it's not like
the happiest moment but the relief is
like the happiest moment well it's cuz
like I I agreed with him I was like dude
yeah I probably do because cuz then I
went down Google rabbit holes and for a
month you were like you're looking up
all the people you and you're
like they might have AIDS they might
have AIDS yeah I really was like dude me
and all the I like looked at myself like
with all the people that have died of it
and like yeah I'm in the boat did it
actually take a full 30 days to get the
results back yeah it took straight up 30
days so for a month you were like oh my
God you're like closing up your life I
was just like kind of like shook up I I
was very unresponsive you didn't think
about like I didn't do very many Buck
buckets like checklist bucket list
nothing no you think that's how it goes
but because it's a stasis it's like I
don't know for sure but I think I am
it's like well let me just find out at
the 30-day Mark and then when he tells
me got AIDS and I'm like I'm going to
move to a small ass town be a cashier
it's almost a relief to find out already
right I was like how am I going to lie
to everybody that's all I was thinking
it's like how am I going to lie to
everybody Magic Johnson has HIV is HIV
positive and that will
never die he's not anym he's not he beat
it he he he doesn't even test uh
positive any from like from like a th
blood transfus or something I think he
got so many blood transfusions that he
got enough uh new blood in where it
regenerated and all the bad ones came
out the joke on South Park is that he
found the Cure and then when they
finally get him to admit what it is he
took all of his money liquefied it and
injected it yeah yeah yeah you need that
much money to to not have AIDS that's so
funny but yeah that was the happiest
that I can remember I ever was do you
think when they told Magic Johnson like
you beat AIDS he did a back flip and
landid on the back
such a dramatic like movie moment I know
it was really it's scary because then
everything that you've been going
through you know when you think you're
in a nightmare or you are in the
Nightmare and you're just like just wake
up just wake up just a dream and then it
really is a dream and you're just like
holy that whole thing was just
that's the best feel did days of
realness did it make you feel like I'm
going to live now like did did your
behaviors change did anything change not
really to be honest like not really but
it was more like okay I'm not going to
do these dark things now right and I'm
just going to be my regular self which
was like like I'm only having sex for
marriage well well that's another thing
is I that's another battle is
you have to try to pinpoint how you got
it so I didn't know did you start
calling girls do you have AIDS you no
but this is the worst part is the person
that I did think that I could have got
it from which was my ex I was too afraid
to ask her because that means something
happened that I didn't know I could face
oh yeah cuz it wasn't me I know I didn't
cheat on her so I'm like like this
episode is brought to you by DraftKings
DraftKings sports book an official
sports betting partner of the NFL
playoffs is bringing you an offer that
will make the playoffs more electrifying
new customers can bet five bucks on any
game and get 200 instantly in bonus bits
scrolly scroll look at these teams look
at these odds for this week oh yeah
who's going to win who's going to make
me some money so download the draft King
sports book app now and use the code off
the Record new customers can just bet
five bucks and get 200 instantly in
bonus bets only on DraftKings sports
book with code off the Record the crown
is yours thank you DraftKings gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit www.1
1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 NY or text Hope NY
46739 and Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
8887895118 on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
and Resort in Kansas 21 plus h varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources so I'm like do I just
die with this like cuz it's not that big
of a deal it's more of a deal that I'm
going to die were you with her at the
moment no oh so maybe your ex gotten a
Jacuzzi with a gay
guy dancer no my ex was a gay guy oh
that explains it but then it
becomes that's a separate battle it's
like how do I tell this person that you
know that you're gay that I'm gay that's
what he's saying that's what's saying
your ex was a gay guy why is that funny
Ken you don't think I can back a gay guy
dude he's not gay his boyfriend is
That's So that's very cliche huh I think
for for me the most recent like super
happy moment no happiest moment of your
life you're one you only get one only
one that's it the correction choose
between Gio or Tao that's it the
aggressive correction I'm doing an
impression to former hosts go
ahead um yeah the most recent one that I
could think uh comes to mind was so
we've been doing these prayer things
with taica at night all of a sudden he's
Christian now yeah yeah we we do these
prayers and so he knows the Lord's
Prayer which is pretty cute he'll say it
all fast and nice and then
afterwards we go in a circle and pretty
much like pray like what we're grateful
for or anyone that we want to like like
bless or have God watch over or whatever
and cuz we're trying to teach him like
it's not about like oh please give me
that bike you know it's not
praying how I used to pray it's either
it's either praying for things you're
grateful for or to like bring protection
to other people so it's like more
selfless that's cool and um on one of
the nights he was like he's like Dear
God thank you for giving me my my super
cool family yeah and like as soon as he
said that I was like oh my God my
god he's like thank you for
giving me my my super cool family my
really cool Papa and my cool mama my my
two cute dogs and also giveing my my mom
this money so she could buy me all these
outfits and make me look
cute sick make me look cute it was so
funny but it was just cool to
like try not to laugh all time this is
what he's grateful for and that's the
goal that me and Gio had so it's like in
ACH and without us like you know when
our parents are like be grateful for
this I didn't even I couldn't even drink
this when I was a kid I'm so grateful
for this it's like it came out of the
kind I'm so grateful yeah thank you
thank thank you that is for this
vegetarian sandwich as you're telling
the story cuz taica with you so
much I thought he was going to bust up
laughing like laugh at you or
something I'm glad that it finished like
nicely it was genuine that could be that
could be like next week yeah he's all
sucker you didn't go thank you for my
butt thank you for my th thank you for
my big butt thank you that I'm Chinese
and nothing else thank you for my
poop well one time um one time cuz I
call his butt steam buns steam bu one
time like during prayer I was like thank
you God for making those ta juicy little
steam buns and he started laughing right
start he started laughing and then the
next day he was I think he was like oh
that was funny so he was like thank you
thank you God for making my mom have
those juicy steam dude that's joke
Jackie don't be jacking my joke that's
that's the complaint that's the I'm like
who are you Carlos menia is that a joke
Jack cuz he said mom's stink buns dude
that's an upgrade bro elevated it he you
did it here he went okay I'm going one
up you all right I'm I got to go back
and think to other on you got a workshop
what did GI say he was like she was
laughing but then she's also like you're
this supposed to be a serious moment but
then it's cool cuz then like now he
knows that if we wanted to we can sneak
little humor into the prayer and it
makes a little okay now he sees the
options stey Ste juicy pork dumpling man
cam what was yours the ioska
thing he says I'm a so happy all the
time I'm never happy one time I was
being ironic but not ironic I actually
think the happiest moment is currently
what I'm going through right
now like right now right now let me what
do he thinks to throw at him are you
talking about right now like Saturday I
mean Friday right now or just whatever
the right now is check it out
dude my work life is in balance my
family relationship is in Balan my girl
situation
is like I'm in the process you like I
have like everything I've always wanted
in my like Social Circle family so
everything like I have great friends
like great times dude every night me and
my friends like we go on Discord and
we're always like joking around
and playing games just doing and I
like I never had that is that like Tyler
Kai like them uh no not them they I do
enjoy hanging out with them yeah no not
those no no no it's it's my high school
it's my high school homies it's David oh
yeah I've played multiple GTA Group G
with these guys they're fun we go to the
gym and like my lifestyle is like
exactly where I want it right now and
like coming into the office it's all
sick now like everything in I
feel like in my life is just getting
like better and better without me really
doing anything like cuz everyone around
you is doing all the work ry's over here
slaming away no but that's what it feels
like obviously like I I want like you
know my career and everything to be
going in an upward trajectory and I feel
like I did all the things like the daily
task to get it to where I'm like oh I
already know it's going to go up from
here so now I'm just like enjoying the
ride that's really actually that's
really Co because like even though
will get thrown at me I already know I
have the mindset to overcome it so I'm
just like all right let's just sit back
do work hard uh be healthy whatever and
then just enjoy life that's how I feel
like right now congrats bro that's
awesome man
thank you I told you to edit that out
though because you look like cuz we
built it up and we were on you at
first and also how do I get on the
Discord I want to be also what's the
punch line in that whole setup it was I
don't know we were make fun of it in the
beginning month months no that is really
cool man I'm thankful for the juicy
steam buns but also like joke jacking
that's joke jacking that is joke jacking
yeah t don't do that no but I do I did
add one thing to my uh daily routine or
my nightly routine now every night I do
sit down I'm freaking in the
cross leg position I just think about
all the that I'm thankful for just
quiet like right before I sleep like
every night cool gratitude I do that but
I think upon my enemies and how I will
defeat them oh yeah do you ever think
about us huh all the time all the time I
always go like okay I'm thankful for
these people blah blah blah and then I
go to sleep what are you thankful for
really though like Nick just wants you
to give him praise yeah praise him
already so can the
video If you go ABC like Pick n yeah
yeah yeah or just like on this table
like what you what are you thankful for
about Nick how has he made your life
better yeah dude his bullying has really
like toughen up my skin dude let's go
hey shut up sorry my bad that was your
time I shouldn't be but for real though
like everything dude that's that's
happiest moment is right now for sure
that's really cool I want to beat your
ass for and then like 10 years later I
look at this video I'm like man I
wish I was you're like that guy's
gay that dude's gay oh
[Music]